peut-être que pour vous il y aura un
lendemain mais pour certains d'entre
nous se jouerait le dernier salut bon
base mot dire non vous rêvez ce soir
grosse teuf film la mère est absolu
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fous il s'est passé
quoi hier soir de quoi est-ce que tu
parles comme une impression de déjà
cette impression toute la journée
est-ce que ça va
c'était pas en rêve ça s'est réellement
produit de nouveau
parce que l'espoir est la seule chose
qui puisse donner un sens à l'absurde
et attention aux camions qu'elle camion
[Musique]
il fallait que je fasse quelque chose
les choses pouvaient peut-être changé
je pouvais peut-être tout changer
trout sait jamais trop tard
est-ce que tu as besoin nuit tu peux me
faire confiance du sel et c'est
réciproque
non
peut-être que pour vous il y aura un
lendemain mais pour certains d'entre
nous se jouerait le dernier
mais je ne savais rien de tout ça avant
de le vivre